before we say goodbye let's play a quick
round of truth or dare
hi we have rose rosado
hi hi rose hi
hello
all right we know it's a dare because we
see this little set up here but we do
not know what is happening what are we
doing
okay so we're gonna be spicing things up
a little bit today oh gosh you're gonna
be eating jalapeno peppers while you get
to know me a little bit oh yeah by the
way i'm so excited you love hot things i
mean not so much
frosting okay look at oh god look at
those
okay
these by the way that's a sizable pepper
i'd say
in the pepper world yes yes good luck
okay
so
oh god um
hey rose so what's your favorite time of
day
uh night time
you've always admired you sadistic woman
that would have to be my mom she came
here from puerto rico and was always a
strong woman that i admire i love that i
love moms i'm not sure about you but i
love your mom
okay do you have any pets
i do i have three chihuahuas and a
cockatoo with a big personality can i
finish now do i have to eat the whole
thing
i mean drew's doing pretty well
can you do it can you finish the whole
thing
okay
oh my god
this is outrageous you're not going to
do it
are you single
no
look for a boyfriend you got boyfriend
your girlfriend would you like it
i have a boyfriend yes
okay what's your proudest accomplishment
um getting my master's degree it was
kind of like a thank you back to my
parents can i just ask why you why you
made us do this
so it's funny because i can't handle
spicy foods i just want to kind of test
you guys out
yeah yeah you did great though
this is the only thing left
wow
i can't believe you did that
oh
good
it's been a real pleasure
thank you for choosing to spend your
time with us
[Applause]
we make this show for you
make it with you
[Applause]
[Music]